what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the single biggest twist
in all of attack on Titan and one of the
biggest twists in all of anime the
attack on Titan anime has finally caught
up to the part of the manga where the
massive basement mystery is revealed and
this single revelation throws everything
we thought we knew about the world of
attack on Titan out the window and
changes everything not just for us the
fans but also for the characters who
live in that world if you read the manga
or seen the third season of the anime
you know the crazy twist that I am
talking about but in this video I will
not only be talking about what happened
in the basement I will also be talking
about how the basement shifts the entire
narrative of the attack on Titan story
and moves the plot to a whole other
level the basement changes everything an
attack on Titan and I would argue that
it makes the already captivating story
even better and even more relatable to
all of us who are reading and watching
it if you enjoyed the attack on Titan
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar please consider subscribing
and hitting that notification bell at
the very beginning of the attack on
Titan story we are introduced to the
Titans giant mindless monsters who want
nothing more than to devour humans the
behavior of these Titans is very similar
to the behavior of zombies in popular
zombie horror fiction but the Titans
have the added advantage of being giants
compared to normal humans because they
don't appear to have much intelligence
overall and because their sole purpose
seems to be to devour humans the Titans
are the embodiment of mindless evil the
Titans are a force of nature
monstrous villains that seemingly have
no moral worth or agency as such members
of the survey Corps and the other human
characters have no sympathy for the
Titans and they feel no remorse when
killing them after all these are big
dumb monsters who want to devour you so
it makes sense for you to defend
yourself by killing them our protagonist
Eren holds this exact view at the
beginning of the story as a child he
always dreamt of venturing
beyond the walls that separate the
humans from the Titans and he hated that
these evil Titans prevented him from
exploring and enjoying the outside world
after the fall of Chicago that district
and the death of Aaron's own mother at
the hands of a Titan Aaron's dislike for
the Titans turns into an obsessive
hatred he vows to destroy every single
Titan in order to avenge his mother and
in order to ensure that no one else will
have to suffer at the hands of the
Titans at this point
Aaron's hatred of the Titans is
reminiscent of captain Ahab's hatred for
a whale named Bobby dick Captain Ahab
loses a leg to Moby Dick and after that
he begins obsessing over getting his
revenge on the whale but here is the
problem a whale is just an animal a wild
beast a whale is driven by instinct he
is just looking for food and trying to
survive there is no ill intent on the
part of the whale towards the captain
and because of this it is impossible to
get revenge on an animal an animal isn't
out there plotting to deliberately hurt
humans if it hurts humans it is because
it was in the process of following its
natural urges and the humans somehow got
in the way in the same vein in most
cases an animal cannot fully understand
that what it did in the past was wrong
so the idea of exacting revenge on an
animal will always be a fruitless
endeavor and the same appears to be the
case with Titans at least in the
beginning Titans are mindless creatures
following their natural urges and
instinct nothing more they don't have
any ill intent or malice they just are
the way they are it is impossible to
exact any form of meaningful revenge on
a Titan you can try to kill all of them
so they can't hurt anyone else in the
future but you can't make a Titan
understand the consequences of their
actions in the same way that you could
make a human understand this is what
makes the Titan such excellent and
horrifying villains they are a force of
nature as unflinching unthinking and
inescapable as a hurricane you cannot
reason with them you cannot relate to
them all you can do is fear them and
their hunger however as the story goes
on we find out that humans can actually
turn into Titans we first realize this
when aaron is about to be eaten by a
Titan but instead he himself turns into
a Titan and proceeds to kill a bunch of
other tight
in his own Titan form now on the one
hand it is cool that Aaron can become a
Titan and use a Titans immense power to
fight against other Titans but on the
other hand it is extremely difficult for
Aaron to understand why he can turn into
a monster how can he
the person who swore to kill all the
Titans actually be one himself this very
concept that humans can become Titans is
a huge game changer but because Aaron
can turn back into a human after he
becomes a Titan the other Titans who
can't are still seen as mindless
monsters our first indication that
something is off even with the mindless
Titans is the 34th expedition and a
Titan that was encountered by Ilse Lang
gnar during that expedition not only
does this Titan not eat Elsa and when
they come across each other but this
Titan is shown speaking too ill say and
even bowing to her and showing respect
shocked that the Titan can speak Ilsa
tries to question it about its motives
the Titan becomes uncomfortable and
starts facing an internal struggle of
some kind
eventually Ilsa tries to run away but
the talking Titan grabs her and kills
her in the process
however the Titan instantly feels
remorse and cries this is the first
indication that we get that even the
mindless Titans have human abilities
like speech and emotions like reverence
and regret of course we later learned
that all the mindless Titans were once
human beings and that they were all
turned into Titans against their own
will the talking Titan who killed Ilsa
is a former member of the cult that
followed Amir from the 104th Training
Corps when she was being worshiped as
the reincarnation of Emir fritz in this
talking Titan appears to have confused
Ilsa with Amir because of their similar
appearance the thing that struck me the
most about the talking tightened before
I read the manga and before I knew the
truth about the basement was how the
Titans seemed to be struggling against
its own instinct to harm humans and
although it alternately failed to
contain its violent tendencies the
talking Titan clearly did not want to
hurt Ilsa the revelation that all of
these seemingly evil Titan monsters are
actually humans who were turned into
these monsters against their will and
who kill other humans only because
their natural urge and not because of
any malice or ill intent really throws
everything we thought we knew about the
world of attack on Titan for a loop from
this point on the video will contain
manga spoilers beyond the current
episodes of the anime so if you're a
strict anime only proceed with caution
you have been warned
suddenly our heroes from the survey
Corps realized that every time they
killed a Titan thinking that they were
just doing the world a favor by
destroying a monster
they were also killing an innocent human
being in the process of course the
Titans were often killed in pure
self-defense and the sea record didn't
have another choice but it was still
such a traumatizing experience for them
to learn that all of these monsters that
they hated and rejoiced in killing were
just innocent people people like
Connie's mother or grisha's first wife
and speaking of britches first wife as a
result of the discoveries found in the
basement
Eren and the others realized that not
only was every Titan once a human being
but in fact Titans are not even the
ultimate villains of the attack on Titan
story it turns out that humanity outside
the walls has not perished and the
humans behind the walls are not the last
remaining humans on earth outside the
walls humanity is thriving and the
humans outside the walls have developed
more advanced technology than the humans
inside the walls including photography
airships advanced military weapons and
so on however the humans beyond the
walls are not living in peace in fact
the basement reveals that the humans
behind the walls are living on a large
island called paradise and that they are
one segment of an ancient nation called
ldiots nearly two thousand years ago an
ancestor of the LD ends called Emir
fritz somehow gained the power of the
nine Titan shifters
and she used that power to form a great
LD an empire that ruled over much of the
world nevertheless the Empire eventually
collapsed because after Amir's death the
nine Titan shifter powers were held by
various LD and noble families and these
families use them to wage wars of
dominance against each other
tired of all the brutal infighting among
the LD and noble families the 145th LDN
king called car
fritzsche decided to abandon the
continent that aldia dominated and he
moved a segment of the Audion to the
island of paradise there he used the
founding Titans power to construct the
three walls and he also used the power
of the founding Titan to erase all the
memories of the outside world from all
the LD ins on the island this way the
145th King isolated himself from all the
war and suffering on the continent and
he threatened the outside world saying
that if anyone interfered with the
affairs of the island he would release
millions of wall Titans and have them
flatten the entire earth after the 145th
King abandoned the continent the LDN
Empire collapsed and the continent was
taken over by the rival nation of Marlay
the marlins now treat the LD ends on the
continent as subhumans and they oppress
and abused them they keep them in
internment zones forced them to wear
armbands that identify them as LD ins
and they use the power that the LD ins
have to turn into Titans as a weapon of
war because they have been using the
power of the Titans to their advantage
the Marlon nation has been able to
subjugate other nations of the world to
its will and while these are the
generally accepted facts the truth about
the LDN empire is drastically different
depending on who you ask according to
the marlins emir fritz made a deal with
the devil in order to gain her power and
the LDN empire was oppressive and cruel
ethnically cleansing the globe for
nearly thousands of years before it was
finally overthrown because LD ins are
the only group of people capable of
turning into Titans Marlins consider LD
ins to be children of the devil and the
entire ethnic group is portrayed as
inherently evil the LD ins are treated
as demonic people who must be punished
for their original sin and for the sins
of their ancestors even if the current
LD ends did nothing wrong themselves
this version of history is clearly
designed to make the Marlins look like
the victims and to justify their
terrible treatment of LD ins including
their exploitation of LD ins for the
purposes of war on the other hand among
the audience who are still living in
Marlay there was a rebel group called
the LD n restorationist s-- and Aaron's
father Grisha was a prominent member of
this group
the restorationist believed that he mere
Fritz's titan powers were a key
from God and that the LDN Empire was
just and benevolent the ancient LD ins
used Titan powers to build roads bridges
and other important infrastructure and
all of this greatly advanced the
progress of humanity rather than seeing
LD ends as inferior in the way that
Marlins do the LD and restorationist see
the audience as superior to other
nations and they believe that LD ins
should once again rule over others the
truth is that both of these drastically
different views of history are very
self-serving and they feed into the idea
that one group is superior to another
where lands believe that they are
superior to the LD ends and that the
audience must be dominated by Marlins
and Aldi and restorationist believe that
they are superior to the Marlins and
that they should rule over them however
the owl
Ehren Kruger an LD and rebel who
infiltrated the upper echelons of the
Marlin military explains to Grisha that
it is likely that both of these
one-sided versions of history are wrong
in Chapter 88 of the manga Ehren Kruger
talks about the power of propaganda and
how anyone can become a God or devil
depending on which version of a story
people believe to be true Kruger says
that there is no such thing as truth in
this world and it is likely that
everything we think we know is actually
propaganda if LD ins were deliberately
ethnically cleansing the world for
almost 2,000 years as the Marlins
claimed then there would be no one left
alive today except for ldiots but at the
same time Kruger points out that he has
never met any human being who is as
completely benevolent and great as the
LDN restorationist claimed that their
ancestor Amir fritz was it is highly
likely that both versions of history
contain elements of fiction exaggeration
and propaganda but if a large group of
people begin to believe all of these
things then in their minds this becomes
the truth and the actual truth no longer
matters this is the same lesson that we
learn from George Orwell's famous book
1984 there is a well-known quote in that
book which states who controls the past
controls the future who controls the
present controls the past this means
that our understanding of history will
inevitably shape our outlook on the
future
and those who have the power in the
present can use that power to manipulate
our understanding of history so for
example Marlins force all ldm children
to learn about how their ancestors were
evil and how they must atone for the
sins of their ancestors by showing
unquestioning loyalty to Marlay they
brainwash the LDN children by feeding
them a very one-sided version of history
that makes Marley look good and aliens
look terrible on the other hand the LDN
restorationist
accused all Marley on official history
of being nothing but manipulative lies
designed to slander ldiots but the LDN
restorationist constructed their own
version of history that puts Ameer Fritz
and the LD ins in an exclusively
positive light and they did this based
on ancient historical documents that
they found documents which talk about
ancient el dia however the LD and
restorationist s-- are actually unable
to read the ancient language that the
documents they found are written in so
they are constructing their version of
history solely based on a few vague
images that they found in these books
they don't actually have concrete
evidence for their version of history
either i completely agree with aaron
Kruger when he says that both versions
of history are clearly self-serving and
are very likely false even if they
contain some kernels of truth and this
is the beauty of attack on Titan and
this is my favorite part of the entire
story the true message of attack on
Titan is that all history is subjective
all history is written by the victors
and human beings have inherent biases
that cloud their judgment furthermore
the greatest enemy of mankind are not
zombies or giant monsters or even modern
weapons the greatest enemy of mankind is
man as hanji points out after the
revelations from the basement the Titans
are not the true enemy the true enemy is
humanity there is a famous phrase in
Latin homo homini lupus' esthe and it
means man is a wolf to man simply put
even though we as humans are so much
more intelligent than wild beasts we
often still treat each other like wild
beasts clearly the Marlins who abuse the
aliens are doing terrible and unjust
things look no further than the fate of
gracious sister
for confirmation of that fact even
though many Merlin's behave in terrible
ways towards LD ins there are also
summer lands like Theo McGrath who are
more tolerant towards ldiots on the
other hand there are of course many LD
ants were good people but there are also
LD and who are cruel and evil for
example there are no more lands behind
the walls on paradise but even without
the marlins many LD ants treat each
other terribly and if we just look at
how the minority bloodlines like the
Ackerman's were treated by the military
police behind the walls we can see that
the world of attack on titan is just
like our own world just like in our own
world no nation is completely pure or
completely evil there are good people
and bad people in every nation and there
are good people and bad people on both
sides of conflicts the world is not
black and white and the biggest message
of attack on titan is to warn us about
the power of propaganda and the tendency
of human beings to treat each other
cruelly in the name of fictional
narratives which have little basis in
reality
despite incorporating fictional titan
powers into the story the world of
attack on titan is a powerful reflection
of our own world and all of its many
problems
unfortunately this important message has
gone over the heads of some people
especially people who don't take the
time to fully comprehend the attack on
titan story i have seen way too many
individuals taking to twitter and other
social media to accuse attack on titan
of promoting authoritarianism and other
nonsense because they saw manga panels
which contained images of internment
zones and people with armbands because
they don't take the time to actually
read the story they see these panels of
LD ends in Marlay which remind us of the
horrors of world war ii and they
immediately accuse the creators of
attack on titan of promoting the inn
justices of world war ii nothing could
be further from the truth and i may have
actually make an entire video just on
this topic because of how often I've
seen people make these claims out of
ignorance and without taking the time to
actually understand the context merely
referencing world war 2 does not mean
that the author is promoting the horrors
of World War 2 on the contrary
attack on Titan teaches us an important
lesson propaganda exists and it has
terrible consequences humans can be
manipulated into doing horrible things
and war is always a complex multifaceted
and in the end uh Turley tragic
occurrence no one who takes the time to
understand the story of attack on Titan
could ever make the claim that attack on
Titan glorifies war attack on Titan
clearly shows us the cruel truth about
war and the devastating consequences of
lies and propaganda at a time when
people who actually remember firsthand
the horrors of World War two are in
their late 80s and older it is so
important for stories like attack on
Titan to remind the younger generation
that war and propaganda are horrifying
things that should be avoided at all
costs and this is why the basement
changed everything an attack on Titan
the basement transported us from a
fantasy world where the main villains
are fantastical giant monsters into a
world that is all too similar to our own
world a world where the true enemy of
humanity is none other than humanity
itself that is such a profound narrative
shift in such an important lesson for
all of us and that is why attack on
Titan is easily my top 5 anime and manga
of all time but let me know what you
guys think how did the basement change
your perspective about the story of
attack on Titan and how did you react
when you first fully understood this
incredible twist give me your thoughts
down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell a huge thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for supporting our
work I want to give a special thank you
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh chubs is the
man and nothing but a fan and another
huge thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah a Lola nod of Maddy Mac and
Michael Calderon if you guys feel that
our content provides value for you and
you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and you
our name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]